I have a message for every politician
right now in Ukraine in here in the Ross
to everyone in Europe around the world
if somebody
think the war is somewhere far away from
me
the the war doesn't touch me personally
is the biggest mistake
this war and the largest country in
Europe can destabilize situation in
whole region
this war can touch everyone in Europe
also everyone in the world
we have never forget Ukraine Ukraine
have five nuclear planes and one of them
a couple of weeks ago was in the fire
if they explode this will be much bigger
tragedy than in Chernobyl catastrophe
and the world in dangers and that's why
right now the unity of all countries
uh the key for peace in the Ukraine
is very important to stop the war it's
very important to be United it's very
important to make a press to the Russia
and very important to make a sanction is
very important
to for Ukraine to be free country
Democratic country will be independent
and with Turtle Integrity is very
important question for us as Ukrainian
was the consequences of this war and the
consequences eventually are very scaring
Ukraine is one of the biggest
delivers of green to Africa and Asia and
with the blocking of the Black Sea
obviously we will have hunger in those
regions
and it's not just those regions or just
Ukraine and so to speak
war that is localized in Ukraine is
going to spread further we've seen from
the outside in Europe the incredible
courage of the Ukrainian people to fight
the Russian invasion in in key Health
the city which you are my the Russians
were fought back and pushed them back
people said this until three days
and you control the city give us an idea
of what it has been like in Kiev during
that fight
a simple explanation why Ukrainian
Soldier fighting so tough and actually
destroyed the uh
they
strongest army and the image of strongs
are in the world Russian army the
Russians have more soldiers more weapons
the equipment much better but as former
fighter I tell you it's not about this
size and the power it's much more
important the spirit in will to win
uh
Ukrainian in the Airy War the peoples
died
you a Russian soldier got paid
and fighting for the money
Ukrainian Soldier defending our city
our country our family
our children and the future of our
children the good question for everyone
are you ready to die for the money are
you ready to diet for you family for
your children
can I show you something this is uh we
have a reporter and a team right now in
the Don Bass
can I just show you this is the filming
they have done for the last few days
everyone begins to panic at what sounds
like cluster bombs Landing far too close
by we head for the doorway to shelter
open the basement for Larry shouts this
is some of the
footage our teams have seen how do you
feel when you see this war happening
it's still continuing
the war has horrible face
we saw the consequences in
satellite cities as bushing a tunnel
just to name a few
um
the war has horrible face we've seen all
those dead bodies of young women men
older men
um
being just killed you could tell they
were tortured before
execute it with the headshots
with the tight hands behind the back
you could see you could smell
you could tell the Silence of the death
and destruction of all the
infrastructure and buildings
so War has many horrible faces
and this war was started
by Russia
and now
this war
Russia is trying to justify why this war
was started
and I believe that
isolation of Russia
why the world is extremely important
if we don't stop it if we don't sanction
it if we don't isolate it with one front
on gas oil
call
athletic team here in Switzerland the IC
in Los Angeles IEC headquarter
and it's not just the decision must be
made too to isolate
from the next upcoming Olympics the
Russian team
nothing is the athletes or nationalities
but to show to Russia this war and the
world is not okay with that this war
crime must be stopped
and the consequences must be taken
by the international Court
that already took place also by the
Ukrainian court and one of the soldiers
Russian soldiers confirmed that he was
ordered to kill that old man on a
bicycle
he didn't say I didn't do it he
confirmed I did it because the command
was to kill him
so
um yes it is unbelievable as you just as
you just asked really that's exactly
what I'm
asking like really how could you do I
mean
to shoot an old man on the bicycle well
those war crimes must be punished and
have consequences you guys were Fighters
you're now
in a much much bigger fight for your
country is Ukraine going to win
where does it have another choice
uh give up it's not the options
are we fighting for our future
for our families
for for our countries and the
we we're more than sure
we stopped this war and Ukraine will be
free from aggressors
and Ukraine will be part of European
Democratic family